we heard angry words from the president
abbas there saying america and israel
should go away
what does he mean by that well it's been
far
too long adam that people have been
subjected to
a very uh concerted
constant campaign of simple denial of
their
of their of their rights of subjugation
of besiegement of ethnic cleansing of
displacement and placement i mean go
people are tired and the president is
representing his people but israel go
away
sounds like you're saying there
shouldn't be a jewish state
okay but let's not get there that's not
what he meant
no no what we meant israel must end its
occupation it must end its
discrimination and racism
israel must behave if it wants to be a
state within the international system
according to international rules and
israel since its
inception did not and it has been
violating every single rule
right we haven't been together we know
the tensions around
the uh that's acts of the temple mount
we know about the
ethnic tensions in israel but that
people are dying now because of the
exchange of missiles and bombardment
yeah there is
there is fire definitely yeah do you
support the firing of
missiles uh into israel and the there is
a fire ball now and innocent people are
being affected yeah i understand that do
you
support the heartbreaking images that
came from gaza
but who started the fire that's the
question and every time
every time we come back to sky and other
news outlets and we discuss this yeah
but the question
and we discuss you want to discuss the
reaction the question that the
rest of the world is very concerned
about the human suffering wants to see
is an end to these missile exchanges and
israel is saying
it's retaliating and that if those
missile exchanges rocket exchanges stop
uh that it would stop the bombing but do
you think uh stopping the
exchanges would stop the ugly reality
that started this whole thing
well it would stop people being dying
and being blown up
no palestinians are dying every day with
exchanges
or not they are dying every day so i
come there you have a palestinian mother
saying goodbye i come back to this issue
you represent fatter you represent i
represent palestine well you represent
the government which is the fatter
government of abbas
this is being done with hamas over by
hamas over whom you have no control
isn't it
no this is done by the palestinian
people everywhere so this palestinian
the palestinian people not only in gaza
the palestinian people in gaza in
jerusalem
inside this i mean i know israel
i know you're from gaza you were born i
was born in gaza i lived in gaza
i know the faces that were uh bombarded
by israel the last two days i know
some of these families uh therefore to
focus primarily
on the symptom on the the outcome
yeah and to forgot to forget the input
the input the
the provocation by israel the sheer [ __ ]
i accept that but right now it's because
of
the exchange of of missiles and and
bombs that people are dying and
suffering and in gaza
buildings are being demolished and that
that would stop
if if the missiles stopped wouldn't it
no no i don't people are dying every day
because of
israeli occupation because of the
israeli draconian system
because this state no no no you won't
get you're a diplomat you won't get back
to the diplomacy
while there is a hot war going on will
you yes but the hot diplomacy need not
just to
put off fire they need to revisit wi-fi
fire started because this has been
happening
every couple of months you invite us
because people are dying
we need to that's why my president
yesterday said enough
is enough get off our backs so this is
an opportunity adam this is an
opportunity
not to have all these people who so how
do we how do we practically
with a new american administration and
all the rest of it how do we practically
get to a situation
where this violence stops and where
the grievances which you've outlined can
be addressed again by the international
community very simple israel must leave
us alone
just get off us our backs leave the
occupied territories
occupation military occupation is by
definition temporary
you cannot have a military occupation
for 54 years
let alone if you use this military
occupation to actually
displace and replace people as you have
been doing
but this is what is happening and i'm
sorry for all these years the
palestinian people have been subjected
to
a system of ethnic cleansing now we're
done with that
so the issue is not just exchanges the
world needs to come and help
you see the the fear is that
organizations you've represented and i
know you were
a diplomat in america until the uh
president trump decided that he wasn't
going to
allow that recognition that what's going
to take over
is going to be hamas who many people
regard as terrorists backed by the
iranians
and you know that's one of the reasons
why you had to suspend the election i'm
sorry adam the
international media including british
media always try to paint the picture as
if it's an issue between hamas and
israel no it's an issue between
palestinians
people and israel we hamas was created
only what
20 years ago this has been ongoing for a
hundred years but it took control
doesn't it
no it didn't okay yeah i mean are the
iranians what i'm only asking no you
have palestinian leaders
you have the plo that i represent yeah
sure you have the state of palestine
acknowledged recognized have a seat in
the u.n uh this isn't
just you know this this reductionist way
so how would you how would you reducing
our cause
to some sort of conflict so you don't
you don't you don't believe iran
no no i don't care i don't care i i care
about
the palestinian mothers who are now who
are now fighting for the lives of their
children i care about the thousands of
palestinians who are now
in the streets trying to have their
voices and what do you say
i care about the agony yeah the wounds
the people the immediate agony could be
ended if the missiles stopped couldn't
it no no no no no
this is not about the missiles this
isn't about the missiles this
is about those people being killed by
the israelites i hope
i hope all this will will stop okay soon
and there are
concerted diplomatic efforts uh our
president is on the phone with everybody
the u.s
is sending a very senior envoy i hope
this will stop soon but adam
if you if this stops you think israel
will stop
you will stop evicting people from from
their homes
will stop killing as you know the
british government international
community
opposes the what do we do with opposing
did the international community do its
own responsibility
to actually stop israel from doing those
did britain really take up its historic
and moral responsibility you know it all
started here a hundred years ago
no no it's important to remind the
british audience and the international
audience the united kingdom
with that moral arrogance promised our
land for other people without even
consulting us
and since then we have been in an
ongoing agony
this position i do i'm about to speak to
united nations diplomat and that's why
the union and i want to ask you what
diplomatic
moves you want to see firefighting is
important we need firefighters now to
put off the fire
but we need law enforcement we need the
international community to enforce
its own laws adam we need the
international community to come and tell
israel listen
there are consequences to illegalities
okay we have established this
system the international system so we
don't go back to the horrors of the
second world war we will not allow
israel
that's what the uk should be saying and
the world to be above the law
the culture of impunity must end if the
world starts really
behaving like law enforcement if israel
becomes under
the law and not above it i assure you
peace
will be within reach okay but the world
never did that all right
i understand that ambassador thank you
very much indeed for joining us thank
you